talk to us about Vulcan Islam man give
us some insight on that okay so Volk
used to be a fat guy yeah like big boy
Brawley played rugby and thing is when
you walk around with that kind of body
mass for years you develop a different
kind of muscle yeah oh man density yeah
but even with Volk I've tried to hold
him down I'm not the greatest wrestler
even with my frame and my leverage it's
hard to hold him down he finds a way
back up really yeah and he even finds
where to get inside on me sometimes even
striking a lot of he's crafty crafty
veteran his inside leg kick his Jabs his
hand control all that [ __ ] he's crafty
and Islam is great trust me these daggy
boys they know what they're doing they
have their own pedigree
and they're great but again I'm biased
of course you're gonna say that because
it's my boy boy I truly
a gun to my head I could bet uh [ __ ]
like honestly I could bet my whole house
on that I believe it
self yeah it's starting to get soft
hey yo not like me though but
um yeah Valk is just different brovoke
is just the kind of guy that even when
he cuts weight the amount of weight he
cuts for him to have the cardio he has
in the later rounds Jordy will tell you
the fight dietitian will tell you it's
oh mind blowing yeah like different and
the man is different he's just I get so
much every time I do so a spider circle
right
what's that it's the last like it's a
Sunday workout we do it on the day we
fight and we try and time it with the
with the uh either American time or
wherever we're fighting the time so it's
the worst fight of your life
there's a clip of him it was might have
been on my channel years ago where he
like just dumping everyone in the last
round and then the timer went off he
kept on dumping people and they were
like time time every time I do my last
round I always whenever it's time to go
like you're just walking in Walking In
people just walk in you're like yep boom
double leg yup yup yup boom double leg I
try and emulate him he saw his fireman
to me in in so many different ways and
just seeing the way he just blossomed as
a champion as a person and standing in
his own in his own light 10 toes I'm
like yeah [ __ ] yeah talk your [ __ ] yeah
like after his last fight he pretty much
went all of you get your [ __ ] together
if you want a shot of the strap if not
you can all [ __ ] off yeah I'm gonna go
up to lightweight so yeah I like the
fact that he's being himself right now
but um he's different man he's different
yeah
yeah and it's striking as well like
striking I think it was so impressive to
me man because Max first of all I love
Max and he's likewise I wasn't even
talking to volkis like but bro I like
him yeah he's a cool guy he's a cool ass
dude I'm sure if we'll go to Hawaii with
link up he likes anime he can probably
teach me how to surf whatever I mean
that's a cool guy yeah so he's but he
said it he was like he's like yeah but
there's just something something
different even with the Striking to see
him make those adjustments you know and
shout out to the camp Eugene and like
yeah I'm good Joe Uncle Joe Uncle Joe
wasn't part of that but he wasn't white
lady boys
Joe like it when a hooker holds the
mitts
we got to make Joe the most famous coach
yeah